thanks jillian finley acura the sponsor
of this next segment is spreading the
word about how the community can help
our kids have more access to the books
they need and love here's how you can
get involved
my name is travis aguilar we're here at
the valley's best kept secret finley
acura and today we wanted to continue to
do
our community outreach family acura has
been big in the community along with the
finley's for many years whether it's
from
giving away turkey dinners around the
holiday season
or
spreading the word for some of our
other
organizations like spread the word
nevada as we're getting into back to
school season
we thought it's something that's really
important just to help develop some of
our young leaders and reading's key with
that so that's why we wanted to team up
here with spread the word and we do have
lisa habergorst here today to give us
some more detail into what they're all
about here spread the word nevada is so
excited to partner with finlay acura on
this book drive
books are needed more than ever in our
valley our kids have been suffering for
the last year by staying at home they've
lost a lot of learning especially the
children we serve
they don't have a lot of resources in
their home to help their education so
the more that we can get back and get
these books into the homes to help these
kids look forward to a brighter future
by reading by exploring by learning
about different cultures that's what
we're all about is helping these
children spread the word nevada started
20 years ago as a very small community
give back project that we never knew
would grow to the size it is
currently we're in 65 schools across the
state and in our rural areas with boys
and girls clubs partnering
what we do is we put books into the
hands of children who can't afford them
we train families the importance about
reading together as a family and what
they can do to help their children's
education
we also have a mentoring program where
volunteers work one-on-one with
struggling readers
and then we also have a summer reading
program all together those programs have
served over right around seven hundred
thousand kids across our state for these
past twenty years with about seven
million books
so we're very excited about what we do
every month we give out about sixty
thousand books so we really encourage
and employ you to bring in your books
here at findlay acura what we mostly
need is preschool through fifth grade
but our hardest is the fourth and fifth
grade chapter books that kept in
underpants and the magic tree house that
we used to read with our families those
are the ones our kids love but we'll
take any books preschool through fifth
grade so that we can get them into the
hands of those families who need them
and while you're here if you are in the
market
for a vehicle or looking to just sell
your vehicle we are in the market for
pre-owned vehicles so we are given top
dollar on vehicles whether you trade it
in or not swing by let us give you a
professional appraisal
thank you finley acura for sponsoring
this segment if you'd like to drop off
books they're located on auto mall drive
in henderson for more information call
702-982-4100
or visit
findlayacura.com we'll be right back